I have been so nervous about today I literally
have not been sleeping all week if it wasn't
driving today probably would need a drink do
you guys do you want do you want to drive so
we can get a little little cocktail somewhere
when we arrive no but seriously it's been like
20 years since I've be back today we're on the
road heading back to my hometown in Peterboro
where I'm going to be eating like I did in
high school aka before the diet culture days
it's going to be fun probably not a lot
of vegetables but it's going to be fun
[Music] super quick here folks I really want to
talk about my sponsor today hom glob so I'm a
super organized person but I'm a very messy
person and this is quite the Dilemma for me
because I cannot feel organized when things are
messy so I really appreciate the value of having
someone with actual cleaning skills who like sees
a pile and puts it away to comeon lend some much
needed support so homow is a five-star cleaning
service with super affordable prices way cheaper
than most services that I've paid for in the past
and definitely worth it to save my marriage and my
ability to get work done but the way it works is
you go to homog Glow's website to choose the day
and time that you're looking for and the duration
of your cleaning and you'll be able to see all the
available cleaners along with their background
checks photos and reviews so if you have someone
that you've worked with before you can rebook
that same person and you can schedule it for
that week or like a month from now if you want to
rebook your cleanings on a regular basis you can
also sign up for their forever clean membership
which saves you $30 an hour on future cleanings
or unlimited cleanings for $19 an hour all of
which are backed by their happiness guarantee
and the cleaners are really super incentivized to
do a good job because 100% of the cleaning fees
and tips go directly to them I don't know about
you but I just feel like I can work so much more
effic efficiently and calmly when I'm not living
in chaos take home cleaning off your plate using
homag glow head to homag glow.com abyar or scan
the QR code to get your first 3 hours of cleaning
for only $19 country take me home I don't belong
there anymore C Peter we're just driving past and
we had to check out my old elementary school
I was here since grade 5 through grade eight
I guess and my strongest memory was going to the
dance the school dance and you know dancing like
this was it like this no hands up here it's
basically all I got simple times oh Pizza day
yeah Pizza day was the best so that was my house
the trees are gotten a lot lot bigger than I feel
like I remember and in my head of course as a
small child the house is much bigger as well
but it was a very nice little place to to grow
up it was super quiet and our friends down the
street I could just like run down the street and
knock on their door and be like hey do you want
to play we make up some kind of like make b games
but like we were animals or aliens or something
going on maybe the Spice [Music] Girls but yeah
it's a simple time and honestly in high school
I don't think I recall ever having breakfast at
home we were teenagers we rushed out the door we
had to get out really early cuz my mom worked
next door to school so I basically always ate
my breakfast at school and I'm going to show you
what were some of my favorites when we get there
I knew there was a reason I left this place what
the is that come on Brody getting out of [Music]
here so weird so so weird to be back I mean it's
literally been 20 years it's not actually a school
anymore which is too bad because it was like one
of the oldest schools in the area established 1827
I think it says but I have a lot of good memories
and a lot of not so good memories this school
actually had a little bit of an arts program so
I was an Arts student and therefore I was a bit
of a misfit I guess I still kind of am bit of
a weirdo and yeah people were just not always
kind to us art students even our my teachers used
to make fun of us my science teacher used to make
fun of me calling me an artsy fartsy or whatever
and now that I am a Scientist yes science I kind
of want to call him up and say Hey you know you
shouldn't count on me out because you know Arts
kids can do great things in science too but yeah
these were definitely simpler times when it came
to food because I'm pretty sure I started my day
every morning not with a balanced breakfast but
I would come to the cafeteria I'd get chocolate
milk and I'd get a chocolate chip cookie oh and
these ones are not bad looking this is obviously
not from the cafeteria but the calf cookies
were like as big as my head and they were very
undercooked and literally just raw in the middle
and to my knowledge none of us ever got sick I
mean I don't know how that would fly today but
they were so so so good oh they were like that
big and we would just eat a cookie for breakfast
have our chocolate milk and if the cookies were
not ready in time I would literally eat sour
skittles for breakfast while watching the boys
play basketball so yeah Breakfast of Champions
here I mean this one's good I
haven't drank chocolate milk in
years my kids are obsessed with it I'm not
mad about this little breakfast snack here
M it is very very yummy but my teeth already
hurt just thinking about the Skittles and I
cannot believe I just would eat this at
like 7 in the morning before school even
started oh I'm sorry for you guys who love candy
this is not it for me bro no skills all yours
baby you know my mom had a really LAX approach to
food which obviously I'm very very grateful for I
know without a doubt that my eating disorder had
nothing to do with my family because they were
not alond moms or dads they were never pushing
like you know any kind of restriction onto us and
they were totally fine with us having chocolate
milk and cookies and Skittles for breakfast if
we're you know we're old enough to make our own
decisions and these were the decisions that we
made yeah I kind of would end up getting to school
earlier than most people because my mom worked
here she didn't work for the Army it's now like
a I guess an army base um and it always was an
Armory but she owned a montauri school which
kind of was operating out of the armories there
and I always did a lot of the before and after
care for all the kids so I taught private music
lessons for them there um I did kind of like
the daycare I helped clean I helped organize
it was yeah it was a really nice way to grow
up and um kind of dip my toes into into taking
care of kids which obviously I have a passion
for today too well let's go for a little walk
downtown and I'll show you some of the places
that my friends and I used to go for lunch a
I was so looking forward to having pets so one
of our favorite places to go for lunch in high
school was this place that was called pets
and basically was like a submarine shop and
I would eat a whole foot long submarine with
like meat and cheese and whatever else mayo
and get these like really amazing spicy curly
fries and to me that was just like a perfect
balanced meal right like I I had my carbs I had
my my protein I had my fat had my fun my fries
and yeah like there was no calorie counting
there wasn't me thinking in my head oh if I
have the cheese I can't have the fries oh if I
have the fries I can't have a full sandwich I
need to have half a sandwich oh I should only
have a few fries there was never any of that
food chatter right I ordered and I ate what felt
good to my body and Pete's definitely felt good
but anyways I'm hoping some of my old stomping
grounds are still around so let's keep hunting
so as a narty fartsy as they called us we would
spend a lot of after hours in the neighborhood
you know we would have a lot of rehearsals for
different shows we were doing talent shows I mean
my favorite memory performance-wise from high
school maybe in total from high school was the
time that we had a talent show my best friend and
I actually like all of our friends decided to put
on the VMA madon and Britney kissing situation
naturally I was Britney and my best friend who
was gay he played Madonna and he did a fabulous
job and we had the best time and we made out on
stage in front of everyone including my boyfriend
my mom all of our teachers and I got a little for
it but you know so did britne and Madonna and I
learned from a very young age that if you're not
pushing boundaries and if you're not making some
people mad you're probably not making an impact
at all so yeah on Long rehearsal days we would
literally come out here downtown petero to a
parking lot go to the No Frills get ourselves a
half price baguette some hummus for protein and
then of course a little deep and delicious
because I think they were like $2 at the
time I can see why it's 50% off little little
tough little tough also I just realized I don't
have a fork so Savage I know give him one quick
whisk [Music] here you want some brother no this
is a private private private cake then I suppose
and I've put my little fingers in there dreams
and beans dreams of beans we called it dreams
and beans I think it's dreams of beans but I'm
just so happy it is still here I mean I was very
disappointed about the Pete situation but dreams
of beans I literally had dreams about so when
I was growing up my father was very very busy
he was studying to get his PhD then he became
a professor and so I spent most of my daytime
with my mom because she worked next door to us
going to school but it was really always such
a treat when my dad came downtown and took me
out for lunch and by lunch I mean cake because
we literally went to the cafe and just had a
slice of cake for lunch and there's a specific
cake in my mind that I still dream about cuz it
was that good had like honeycomb on the side I'm
just praying that they still have it this is that
this is going to make my whole year my whole life
and I maybe can finally put all of these obsess
of High School Dreams to bed if I could just have
this cake dreams of beans don't let me down okay
so I got a little iced tea cuz that was a staple
when I was growing up I didn't drink coffee
until I don't know maybe University and they
didn't have my cake so I'm just going to have to
keep dreaming about it apparently just haunts me
in my dream this like little honeycomb crunch on
the sides and this like really sweet buttercream
was so good I got to meditate on it but I still
want to support local business so I got this
Cinnamon Toast Crunch I don't know marshmallow
treat uh I'm very excited to dig into this I'm
also going to have to save most of it for Brody
and my kids which they're one and the same Brody
isn't to my children m m this cinnamon that just
hits different oh little spicy so good and I know
a lot of you guys are probably thinking like how
could your parents let you just eat cake for lunch
but I'm actually so grateful for those experience
for a number of reasons I mean once we get older
especially as teenagers we don't tend to spend as
much quality time with our parents and I'm so glad
that I got to have those experiences with my dad
without them being clouded by diet culture that
was like our special little thing that crunchy
honeycomb cake and I'm also so grateful that I
wasn't raised by my parents pushing these moral
messages around food you know where cake wasn't
bad and apples weren't good I don't remember my
parents ever using any kind of language like that
they served generally balanced meals as best as
my mom could and you know they saw us as young
adults able to make our own decisions when we're
out and about with our friends and if I had cake
for lunch I was probably going to want vegetables
or some fruit at dinner when I got home from the
school but yeah my parents tried their damn best
without even knowing it to protect me from diet
Culture by allowing me to have this flexibility
by allowing me to make mistakes by allowing me
to explore my body's needs Etc without any kind
of guilt or shame it was all the other competing
messages around me that actually did the damage
okay so it wouldn't be a day in my life as a high
schooler without going to the mall because as a
teenager there wasn't a whole lot else to do other
than to go to the mall after school at least not
lately but whether whether or not we had dinner
with our parents later on which we usually did
we would always have to stop by the food court
for a snack so I'm going to show you what I would
usually get all right folks pre- dinner or dinner
is served so this is basically a schmorgus borg
of some of the things I used to order when I come
to the food court fries of course just straight
up like this would be the whole meal slash snack
here we got a chicken SE Cesar wrap which I mean
I still love me a chicken Caesar wrap today but
again this was definitely my idea of being like
a super super healthy choice and then Chinese
food but interestingly I would only ever get the
vegetable low man I never would get any of the
meat or the veg on the side but again knowing so
little about nutrition and caring so little about
nutrition vegetable l Main was like a very very
healthy choice to me because it was vegetarian and
vegetarian equated to healthfulness and it's so
interesting to see now how messaging has changed
and we've adapted so many different specific
ideas about what constitutes healthiness but
anyways the Chinese restaurant didn't even sell on
its Lonesome and I'm grateful for that so I got it
as a combo with some veg which I desperately need
right now broccoli broccoli Just Hits different
when you've had cookies and like a cereal bar
for breakfast but you know being in this place
I have to say feels so familiar like it looks
very different than it did when I was growing
up but the feeling is the same and I think the
reason why high school years had such a heavy
imprint on me like I literally dream about high
school every night I don't know why but I can't
shake it but I think it's because my life just
felt so much bigger then so much bigger in the
years before diet culture took its hold when I
wasn't thinking about how many calories were in
something when I wasn't hating my body when I
wasn't trying to think of how many calories I
could burn by dancing I was just dancing because
I was having fun and enjoying it and enjoying
life like my world just felt so much bigger
before I knew that much about nutrition like
the relationships the parties the late nights
the trouble just the fun you know it was just
such a simple time and I guess I just have a lot
of nostalgia R it because of the trauma that I
experienced basically immediately coming out
of high school and tumbling into a KN disorder
and having to work so hard to get myself out so
hard to be able to see the fries and the low man
noodles and the chicken Caesar wrap and think it
doesn't matter like food is food is food is food
and at the end of the day I know my body today and
it wouldn't feel good just having fries at as a
snack oh but these fries are damn good salty but
really really good okay last nostalgic pit stop
before we hit the road I had to go and get a blue
Slurpee so this used to be a 7-Eleven and we used
to come here with our $5 a week allowance walk
you know on the busy road get our Slurpee and then
just like sit on a curb so let's go stretch our
legs relax a minute before I've got a drive home
in track they also had cheese curds randomly so I
had to get those obviously oh sweet it tastes like
one of those coolers that you drink when you were
young but without the alcohol which is probably
even worse I just have a few final thoughts here
because I know that a lot of my followers are you
know teens and young adults and I just want you to
take one very important thing away from this video
do not diet you know adolescence and childhood
is not a time to be restricting in any capacity
I mean ideally we don't get into dieting at any
age or phase of the life cycle but childhood and
Adolescence is a time of rapid growth and bodily
Discovery and as an elder Millennial I have to
say that my relationship with food growing up
was very different than a lot of teens today
because a you know our parents didn't know a
lot about nutrition like a lot of parents do
today so you know like the whole alond mom thing
they existed but they certainly weren't what they
are today and B most importantly we didn't have
social media like bombarding us nonstop with die
culture rhetoric and food fear mongering and
yes the 2000s were unkind in pop culture but
thankfully my exposure to that was at the end of
my adolescent years and also just could never be
as pervasive as social media you know I really
really truly believe that as parents our job is
to try to expose our kids to as many different
types of foods without any kind of morality
attached we shouldn't be teaching our young kids
how to identify different versions of sugar or
toxic ingredients on the back of packaging when
you're at the grocery store like some Wellness
influencers do for their kids these days like that
shouldn't be a flex and obviously as you've seen
today a lot of the foods that I ate while I was
at school with my friends and buddies weren't
necessarily the most nutritious but because they
were never put on a pedestal or given any moral
weight or restricted I never felt like I had to
overeat them when I got the chance nothing was off
limits in my childhood and I'm really grateful for
that it wasn't until I left my parents home and I
finished high school and I kind of like left that
food neutral bubble and I was exposed to the rest
of diet culture that things really went down Sou
but I'm very very confident that had I never been
exposed to dieting After High School I would
have never become as obsessed over nutrition
as I did which of course was what fed into my e
disorder and for people who are seeing all of the
quote unquote junk food I ate in high school
I'm happy to report that I don't eat low man
for lunch every single day I'm not addicted to
Blue Slurpees as you can see I don't even want
to drink this I'm going to bring it home and give
it to my husband cuz I know he will so if you are
a young person watching this please take this as a
cautionary tail there is so much more to life than
just numbers and calories and macros and portions
and you know body weight your world becomes so so
small when you're obsessing over the calories in
a pack of Caesar dressing if you're interested
in nutrition and of course I encourage you to be
that's why you're here that's why I encourage you
to be here try to think about counting colors
not calories and hold on to that innate body
wisdom for as long as you can well folks my
husband's been calling me and probably needs
some support so on that note I'm going to hit
the road I've got lots of leftovers and little
treats to bring for my kiddos and hubby and I
hope you guys enjoyed this video it was really
fun and nostalgic for me to come back for the
first time in 20 years so if you guys like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with your thoughts what you thought
was healthy or unhealthy when you were a young
person and how that's changed over the years
I think this is all really interesting stuff
and I will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye